how's it going guys welcome back to
cmake or you're watching episode
5. today we're going to talk a little
bit more about libraries and how to make
them optional
and i'm just going to show you that
so we're going to be getting deep into
cmake very very soon actually we already
are
let's just be honest okay so we're going
to open our project from last time
if you haven't watched the previous
videos highly recommended to get here
also don't forget to thumbs up these
videos and give
me some support on this channel yada
yada okay so our program was our lord
and savior we're talking about cmake
here
she makes our lord and savior it is the
build system of choice
for pretty much all c
plus plus developers that uh or see even
same
developers that uh that care you know
no i'm just kind of saying that to say i
don't actually mean that
all right so uh it but i do mean that
it's awesome all right so we have this
adder
library we don't really need it it's
pretty pretty uh
you know no bueno but maybe you have a
project that has a bunch of different
libraries and depending on how they're
running it
or why they're running it or or
something like that you just flat out
don't want a library so
what you do in that case is you
make an option so you see there's an
option for
getting the sub modules here you can
turn it off or on
but we would say for example we want to
have the option to
you know not and not use this adder so
we'll say option
use adder so that's basically the
variable name
it's going to be a true or false thing
or on and off however you want to call
it
uh we'll have some text there about what
it is and we'll default it to
on for now and here we can say
a simple library for
adding two floats because that's you
know that's what it is that's just some
information
for the user you can put whatever you
want there of course our library like i
mentioned
in the first episode or whatever episode
we did is entirely useless and just
purely for example so all right so what
we want to do here
is if they change this to off
we don't want to add this subdirectory
so we'll
then have a little if statement here
that says if
use adder add subdirectory
and then we'll end the if there so
there's a little if statement
so there we go now there's a little more
to it than this
and i had to cover the config last
episode because
this can involve your config
okay so there's also a little more to it
than that
so we have this include directory here
so we also want to basically separate
these out
and also have them around an if
statement
which we can do basically anywhere after
we
add this executable but we'll do it all
kind of chunked together here so i'll
make a comment here and i'll just put
adder use logic uh
yeah that'll be fine and
just to make this super quick i'm just
gonna go up here
and start pasting some stuff in here
i'll clean that up in a second but we
basically want to remove the adder from
this whole
section because this is all just the
glfw stuff
cool all right so up here of course we
don't need this glfww stuff
but we now have it within this
uh if use adder so if they choose to use
your adder you add the subdirectory and
then you
include the directories but if they
don't then you just don't do all this
stuff
so that's kind of the gist of it there
there is a little more to it
yeah i guess the best way to do this is
to just put it in this config
and uh let's see we basically just want
a compiler directive here if def
use adder
then we include
adder dot
h
and then we of course end rf here
and now in our core
program which is in our main.cvp we no
longer have to put this in here because
if we didn't add it
to the library list then we don't want
to try to include it it's not going to
find it it's going to have a compiler
error
and we also want to put some if depths
in here we already have this config
so when this config file is built
it's going to decide for us whether or
not to include
that adder so we need a little if def
here too
if def use
adder then we do the see out thing that
we're testing there
and there we go so that should take care
of that
and of course you could have like an
elsif here where
if you have two options like maybe you
have two different
libraries you could use in theory do the
same thing
so you could do some some pretty
interesting stuff here so we could do
for example else if just if they don't
use the adder
we can just say for example
i don't know let's use just the default
and of course we get the same result
so if they're using the adder it's going
to use that library to do it otherwise
we do it this way and you can you know
you can do anything you want with these
if if you have some other directive it's
else if
and you put whatever that is here like
you can say
linux
you could have 132 or whatever it may be
we'll just put a plane
else here
that sounds good to me okay we actually
need to do this differently
c make define
cmake is going to define this
use
and let's see make we have to have let's
see here we got the configure file
already
i think we need to put this option above
that
yeah so we'll put this up here
but we do need to put this executable up
here as well
like so that way we have our
target ready let's add executable target
okay so there's a way we can do this
where we can do this executable
later
so we'll do it after the
configure file but instead of just
having
all this we'll have a list of like uh
different libraries
okay so if we use that or we add the
subdirectory
and then we'll just make a variable
list append
uh the example i'm looking at calls the
extra lives
and it would be adder
and we want to also have a list of the
includes
so this way you could have them all kind
of check if you have a bunch of optional
libraries and you can just keep
appending them
to this list and of course this is
actually the same since that's just the
name of our
directory here the name of the folder a
lot of people like to put right here
uh project source
directory that way it starts from the
root
and then goes to the folder in case it's
in a weird location
that can help and you probably want
quotes around this and now we no longer
need these
and later when we go to add our
libraries
that's when we put these in here
and we won't say public again we'll just
say
extra includes
which will be blank if the library's off
course but
if not we'll actually need it and we'll
also put in here
extra lives
so the link directories needs the extra
lives
include directories these extra includes
and those will only be appended to that
list if you're using that or otherwise
it's just going to be blank
i may have messed up here i don't think
we need this
let's go ahead and give it a run and see
what happens
source here build into out slash build
cool and now we can run it
but we want to kind of be able to we
want to be able to tell if we ran it
because this is going to look exactly
the same either way
so we'll just add some additional text
here such as
using adder live a
not using that or live that way we can
very explicitly tell whether we're using
it or not
since it is defaulting to on if we don't
say anything about it it's just going to
use it
but if we change that option to off
so let's do a new configure since we
changed a few things and we'll
then build yeah i'm trying to avoid
using these commands because
might be confusing to people but i even
though i did explain it
so let's go into out build we already
have
okay so let's just run this or yeah
let's run this executable but first we
want to build
with make and it looks like add was not
declared in this scope
so let's go take a look at our out build
and this config here
says define use adder very good
but we actually need to include it so
we'll go back to this file
up at the top and we'll say
if and that should take care of it
now we'll go ahead and recompile with
build
uh let's go back a few directories
and once again let me just show you this
build real quick all it does is it
changes directory to our out.build and
then it runs make that's all it does so
let's just run that build and it still
doesn't see it why doesn't it see it
extra lives adder extra includes
oh this is lowercase
the library name is lowercase in our
case
because that's what we named it when we
did add library in this cmake
list on text for the adder so i think
that'll fix it
let's run configure again which just
runs
this command here like we typed it in
just trying to be as clear as possible
here
still doesn't see it so we must have
something wrong
with this include directory or we
spelled something wrong
what are we doing wrong see if you can
catch it before i do it's probably
something
really simple
oh this needs to be lower case because
our
header right there is lowercase that's
all it is
okay so now it should work
we'll reconfigure and we'll build now it
builds successfully and we can run it
let's take a look at our run command
here it just changes directory to
out.build
and then runs the program that's all it
does
so we'll do that
and there we go using adder library
and now all we can do is when we run
cmake
when we go cmake well we'll just uh
simplify this sure you could type in
command line since we're since we're
using these sh files
we can just do these options here
and give it more options so we want to
say
use adder and we'll turn that to off
so d for option change name of the
option
and then what you want to set it to so
now instead of on
it'll be off and it will essentially do
the same thing otherwise
and now we can run configure again since
we changed our c
make well we didn't change our cma file
we'll just build then
let me just check out this now we do
need to run configure again so it
updates our
cmake cache to put this change this ad
or two off
so we'll do that and now we'll build
and looks like it's trying to link the
adder but it doesn't find it
so we have a bit of an error there
why is it trying to link let's check out
our build.sh
looks fine configure
let's take a look at our cmake list
so we're only adding it if we're set to
use adder
this target link libraries right here
is what it is so
we're trying to link it when it's not
there
so we need to make it just another list
for that we'll just change this
this is going to be extra include durs
all right because that's just a little
more clear
include durs
this one's going to be extra library
derps
just to make it as clear as possible
make sure i'm getting this right so the
include
extra includers link directories
extra live
livestreams that that sounds a little
weird let's just do leibner's
well the live director is capital a so
i'm kind of
kind of messing this up a little bit
okay so that'll be
there we go and now here we only want to
add this one here
if we're actually linking it so extra
link and we'll just call it extra links
and this one
is the lowercase one
we can put these in quotes it's usually
a good idea to put in quotes if it's
just a
a string
i still haven't found out all the
nuances of when to put these quotes and
when not to
some people say always do if it's any
sort of string
but it's not entirely clear to me
so now we'll just put that right here
extra links
this should clear it up let's go ahead
and configure again
so it rebuilds our cache then we'll do a
build
cross fingers yep built successfully
and then we will run
run there we go not using adder
cool and once again if we change this
and just take this out of here
or put it to on which is its default
anyway
and then do a another configure
another build
another run then we are using the adder
so there you go but there is the
logic for the list and appending
and at the bottom there we just
link all the extras if it's blank then
that's fine they're just not there
and if there's something there then it
does link them and since it has this
option logic
we can toggle it on and off and i'll
once again show
this config it's just cmake define use
adder
and then in our main we have a few
compiler
directives whether we need to include it
or not
and then a little little elsift
for which one we're using so there you
go there's how to option in your
libraries and take it a step further
hope you enjoyed this episode
thanks for watching we'll see in the
next one happy coding